inciso b encuentra la pendiente de la
línea tangente a la trayectoria de la
partícula en el tiempo te iguala 3
así que la pendiente será simplemente la
tasa de variación de i con respecto a x
en ese punto
y esto es exactamente lo mismo que dejé
en dt / / de x dt trabajar con
diferenciales es a veces un poco extraño
cuando quieres ser muy riguroso pero
podríamos ver esto como pequeñas
variaciones en gente variaciones en x y
en t
pero cuando lo vemos de esta manera
podríamos decir oye pues simplemente si
yo multiplicará por dt en el numerador y
en el denominador y observemos que es el
mismo pequeño cambio entonces
cancelarían a las anteriores y
regresaríamos a del sobre de x el que ya
teníamos la razón por la que lo escribía
así es porque la información que nos
dieron es justamente esta ellos nos
dieron de ella en dt y de equis en dt
así que si queremos encontrar la
pendiente al tiempo a ver qué tiempo así
nos dieron el tiempo te iguala tres de
ella en dt al tiempo te iguala 3 va a
ser esto que tenemos aquí arriba que es
el seno de t cuadrada que sería el seno
de 9 y de x en de t al tiempo 3 aquí nos
están diciendo lo que es de x en de t
como una función del tiempo entonces es
cuatro veces este más uno o sea 13 y
ahora podremos evaluarlo directamente
con nuestra calculadora
ya tenemos parte de lo que estuvimos
haciendo y vamos a calcular el seno de 9
entre 13 esto es igual a cero punto 0 31
70 puntos 0 31 7 y ya estamos listos
esto es la tangente de la trayectoria de
la partícula al tiempo de igual a 3 lo
copié bien a ver este si 0.0 31 7
ya estamos parte se encuentra la
posición de la partícula al tiempo te
iguala 3 ellos nos dieron x prima de t y
se prima de t ésta es x prima de t y
estar acá es prima de t
vamos a ver si podemos escribir x de t 7
para poderlo evaluar en 3 así que veamos
necesitamos encontrar x prima en 3 y
prima en 3
xd te será la anti derivada de esto que
tenemos aquí así que la anti derivada de
4 te va a hacer 2 t al cuadrado si tomo
la derivada de esto obtengo 4 t
la anti derivada de uno esté más té más
una constante en esencia lo que hicimos
fue hacer la integral indefinida de este
lado que es cuatro temas uno y de ahí
obtuvimos esta constante que claro al
derivar la desaparece por suerte también
nos dieron esta condición x de 0 es
igual a 0
así que cuando te es 0 este término va a
ser cero este de acá también será cero y
nos están diciendo que todo esto sería
cero entonces se vale cero voy a hacer
lo mejor de manera explícita para que no
nos confundamos
así que x de cero va a ser cero a cero
más c y aquí nos están diciendo que esto
es igual a cero y se es igual a cero
entonces x dt va a ser igual a 2 d al
cuadrado más t así que si queremos ahora
encontrar x de 3 sólo tendremos que
evaluarla
x de 3 va a ser dos veces 9 + 32 veces 9
es 18 + 3 es igual a 21 x de 3 es igual
a 21
ahora intentemos hacer dt y ahora
hagámoslo en un color distinto también
déjenme acomodar la pantalla tantito a
la derecha 7 es igual a si queremos
tomar la anti derivada de esto pero no
es tan fácil sacar la anti derivada de
esto que tenemos aquí de hecho es algo
bastante difícil de hacer de manera
analítica pero tenemos suerte porque en
esta parte del examen nos permiten usar
calculadoras y utilizando el teorema
fundamental del cálculo vamos a decir
que el dt va a ser la integral de 0 a t
de seno de x al cuadrado de x no quise
utilizar una t aquí adentro porque aquí
arriba tengo otra y podría prestarse a
confusiones y tenemos que evaluarlo ente
y también vamos a poner una constante
porque si tomamos la derivada de esto
perderíamos la información que tenemos
aquí y ahora también vamos a calcular
cuál sería la constante porque nos están
diciendo el valor de 0 así que llegue 0
sería la integral de 0 a 0 y esta parte
de acá pues también será cero así que
esto es igual a c y aquí nos dicen que
de cero es igual a menos 4 así que
obtenemos 7 es igual a la integral de
cero a t de seno de x cuadrada de x
menos 4 que es una función de t ya
calculamos lo que es x de 3 y ahora
vamos a hacerlo para allí en 3
entonces la integral de 0 a 3 del seno
de x al cuadrado de x menos 4 y otra vez
tenemos mucha suerte porque podemos
utilizar calculadoras traigamos la
calculadora y ahora vamos a querer
utilizar y de el catálogo de funciones
vamos a buscar y lo que quiero hacer es
la integral definida
así que si la buscó en las heces esa
será aquí está esa es mi función
esta es la integral definida y lo que
quiero hacer es evaluar la integral
definida de esto que tengo aquí
la función es seno de x al cuadrado
esa es la integral definida que quiero
evaluar
de 0 a 3
si de 0 a 3
ops tengo que decir cuál es la variable
de integración primero mi variable de
integración es x y voy a ir de 0 a 3 y
el resultado es
dejemos pensar un poco a la calculadora
punto 77 356 y esto corresponde a la
primer parte esta que está aquí ahora
tenemos que restarle 4 así que si le
quitó 4 tengo menos 3.226 esto es igual
a menos 3.226 voy a verificar la verdad
mi memoria no es muy buena pero si lleve
3 es igual a menos 3.226 la posición de
la partícula en el tiempo te iguala 3 y
está coordenada será la 21 coma menos
3.226